you're originally from was it la or
silicon valley because i know that
that you know you spent some time in in
the tech area because you did get
started with uh facebook
yeah i was born in the bay area so i was
born like literally like a few blocks
from apple's campus so my whole
my first 30 years of my life was all
immersed in that world
how did you how old were you when you
got into facebook that was
about 11 years ago dude it was old man
what was it i was 23
so i was in 2005. so you're basically
what like a senior citizen at 23 at
facebook at the time
no we were the dude it's so funny now
because now at our company appsumo.com
so i was 23 at facebook and i remember
we hired these 30 year olds
and they would leave at five o'clock and
i would always call them such wussies i
was like you guys are such [ __ ] i
cannot believe you're leaving so early
like we stay here all night
um and then like mark had this old lady
as his executive coach
and what i realized though now is now
i'm in my 30s
is that the people who are in their 30s
actually just worked really smart they
came in at nine
they got all their [ __ ] done and they
left at five whereas young dumbasses
were like
i'm here all the time but we're not
actually as productive and
the older people had a lot more wisdom
and experience like mark getting an
executive coach you know definitely
helped him
uh reach these levels that he's at so
how did you get hired at facebook at
employee number 30 because that would
have been
i mean i had a business at one time with
24 or 25 people it was definitely under
under 30 for sure and i knew what that
was like like what did
like what was facebook like at the time
like so i'll tell you a little bit of
the back story so i was in a cubicle
at intel so i i lived at my mom's house
which i know you always tell tell
guys that they're trying to get laid to
live at your mom's house yeah
if you want to get lots of poon yeah
dude
you know 1400 square foot small bay area
house and i was living at my mom's house
and i was doing a lot of these side
hustles
that's what they're called now i was
just doing projects you know i think
it's called a project until you make
money and you know when you support
yourself it becomes a business
and i had all these kind of i did a
discount card called ninja card
i had a college uh craigslist called
college up
i did um i was doing consulting i was
blogging all this different stuff
and um while i was at intel i was like
i'm gonna quit here my dream is to run
my own company and work
abroad like i wanted to like start a
business and then uh
be my own boss and then eventually live
abroad and
i was about to quit and i saw a job on
facebook i just
i think one of the best things that
anybody can do that's young is go work
for the company or the person that you
admire or that you already enjoy and i
didn't there was no other company i
wasn't looking for a job but i was like
i love the site i use it a lot i was
using it to like meet women i was using
it to hire people actually
when was that 2005 you said yeah yeah so
i was just
i think anyone just look at what you're
what it's on your phone go to your
computer history
okay and uh yeah i saw that they're
hiring a product manager
and i was doing all this product stuff
on the side so i think that's kind of a
key thing for people trying to get jobs
is that was really
easy for them to hire me because i'm
like i've been doing this for fun
and making money myself so i just sent
in a resume cold i didn't have any
referrals i didn't have any friends
there
and then when i came in for the job
interview i came with a bunch of uh
mock-ups
i said here's all the things i think you
guys should be doing and i actually did
the work for you
so i think kind of making it a
no-brainer for them to hire me
and uh yeah i got the job it was a
[ __ ] wild thing man like the first
day i still never forgot this
first day i come in my boss doug hirsch
uh doug is now a billionaire from uh
he started good rx which i don't know if
it's up in canada yeah that's uh
that's like a prescription company right
like a farmer yeah yeah it's like you
see my tv
and you get like discounts and stuff but
anyways the first day i come to work and
doug's going to hire me
first they come to work doug is walking
out and i'm like what the hell just
happened mark mark comes up to me like i
just fired your boss
welcome to facebook
i was like all right all right that's
that's different
and so he fired uh because doug wanted
to sell the company to yahoo for a
billion
dollars yeah mark didn't want to sell
and it honestly was probably one of the
biggest professional growth periods i've
ever had
what did they hire you for like what
were you doing there at the time so i
was hired
there's basically in in tech companies
you have developers and designers and
then there's these
product and project managers and the
roles can be kind of blended but i was
hired as a product manager which is
ultimately mark says hey i want you to
improve the ads product like i hear some
things i want
we have to figure out the spec of it the
specifications and then help make sure
it happens
so i worked on facebook ads improving
that getting that going i built the
first facebook mobile product
um i invented status updates so you know
twitter which is basically status
updates like i invented that it started
at facebook before twitter ever did it
so who's the guy that invited that went
and invented the poke button because
that guy needs to get like punched in
the face
you don't like the poke button oh that's
a great one button got got got smashed
like pretty like pretty early on but i
remember back in the early days
everybody would be poking you so and so
poked you poked you
it was fun it was like you were the pope
guy weren't you no i was not but i'm
definitely i was a fan of it because
it's a good way to
you know get people's attention and
early on they remove this really
you know after i was fired they removed
it but you could see who viewed your
profile
so i would go poke girls and poke
ex-girlfriends and see when they you
know
viewed so yeah a little god mode
experience there but dude honestly it
was it was the most like intimidating
nerve-wracking stressful fulfilling time
i think of my career
still to this day which is crazy i was
only there like about a year
and they ended up firing you too and i
know that you lost your
um interest in the business was it stock
options was it options yeah what did
they
offer you at the time they offered point
one percent of the company that was so
many shares i
want yeah because i was watching the
interview that you did with um
wolf of wall street oh yeah and um
i think you said that they at the time
because the video was last summer that
the stocks would have been worth like
something like 600 million dollars
if you had them today yeah now i'm
trying to get ripped
rich on uh crypto so i'm gonna bet it
all richard and hopefully crypto
is gonna make me rich yeah let's talk
about crypto in a minute let's not let's
not skip over the getting fired apart
uh no you know i was depressed for like
you know this is 15 years ago so
sometimes it's wild to reflect on it
yeah and uh i do think it helped me to
have a chip on my shoulder
i think i was wondering if from you know
if i'm honest with you which i'm always
honest but
i wondered how it kept going like i was
like [ __ ] man i got fired by facebook
and i got fired by mint
and then my next company got banned by
facebook we were doing facebook games
and payments and they banned the company
i was like [ __ ] a man like and now
i'm
you know professionally i've made it to
a level that a lot of people call
successful and i would call successful
but
a lot of [ __ ] failures and uh close
calls
and i i think that that chip on the
shoulder from mark kind of
not [ __ ] me over but firing me like
gave me that that drive why did they
fire you was it because of fit
there's a lot of different things i
think now that i'm an employer of people
i would have definitely fired me um i
had a guy
similar to me that was a young buck i
called him he was a maverick
which he's not supposed to be employed
and he always wanted to run his own show
and now he runs his own show and i think
that was definitely similar to me at
facebook
uh i didn't want to be in meetings like
i excelled when we were at 30 people and
then when we got to a few hundred people
you know i didn't want to go to meetings
and have like 80 people literally they'd
have hour
discussions not joking hour discussions
about which font to use
and that's fine that's 80 people in the
meeting no they're probably about 30.
still that's outrageous because i have a
[ __ ] font dude
i just did not that's just that's fine
it's just not where i wanted to i think
i'm like people are dying
like this is not what i want to be
spending time on and i didn't like the
organization at a larger scale
and even though it's 150 seems tiny now
that they have 50 000 people
and you know i think at the end of the
day i needed to accept that like i
probably need to work for myself because
it's not really
i'm not really employable yeah like most
guys that end up building businesses
find themselves in a position where they
can't
like they can't work for somebody else
working for somebody else can be okay if
you can
get decent pay and you've got no risk
whatsoever
then it can be fun but you get a lot
more flexibility
you